nice poster Xena nice porno mag yeah
good thing I'm about to die I hope I get
it all thank you so much yes I know
Simon stop being a giant [ __ ] and get
with the program
gorillas I don't know what that is but
holy hell good is a big baby our new
weird who locked it I did considering
I'm in here what's this what was that
what was that supposed to be I'm gonna
punch this I'm gonna palm step pumpkin
hop how a pouch pouch no punching all
right a punch dad pumpkin in the face
right here we go let's go Oh pills pills
pills Sophie is dead and you're next
okay ouch sorry Sophie I was like a
friendly pouch a friendzone pouch don't
stray from the path or you'll be
punished okay door RPC door RP don't
stray from the path what's the path I
don't see a path boom ah I see you
you're afraid of monsters monsters ah
what how Oh boom boom your bull there's
such bull an older bull how was I
supposed to know that with a path there
it didn't say anything about a path
there was no path I did walk around your
living don't don't stray from the path
or you'll be punished
shut up Sophie how are you please I
don't like this place
you all are gonna die so hard
Wow Jesus Christ you're fast ah lose
your path here the wall is fake break it
down what wall okay
Oh a game like it lots of ammo bottom oh
no like door RPC what's the username
wait hang on here we go
oh ok I get it your RPC unforgettable
four four nine nine four four nine nine
four four nine nine don't go in huh
but I want to go in four four nine nine
I'm gonna go in screw it I'm going in
four four nine ah bollocks Oh
[ __ ] I bawled I forgot how to beat this
guy part you in the back
Oh bad you're quick
okay come on come on come on come on I
know how to be another run out of ammo
here come on
gah bah be eat it [ __ ] I'm gonna have
to just melee him or something come on
Kyla
there we go
come on Mele you [ __ ] okay one more one
more just gotta bring the mail wah bah
all right Oh up there buddy
hold up there buddy whoa whoa whoa whoa
go down go down go down here we go come
on hum hum there we go
[ __ ] you did I won it are warned ah
[ __ ] as a chapter seven holy hell how
many chapters are there oh boy oh it's
game what's down there oh I guess ha ha
I want to go home
oh my god what the hell was that I'll go
home okay stop that startling it's just
kind of surprising what are you doing
here what hell is a daughter not mood to
be here he's not supposed to be here
he'd not go to be here Oh God Oh
oh no he's not supposed to be here he's
not bother me here he's not supposed to
be here he's not by here ah waiter come
up
oh stop it stop it starvin sob mama
hater I can't take it buzz ah you go
home I wanna go ah [ __ ] hell God [ __ ]
dammit where's my [ __ ] gun where's my
[ __ ] gun here it is huh
how much I'm having a bullets for you
[ __ ] what [ __ ]
Oh God how many bullets does it take to
kill you [ __ ]
Jesus it's like they knew I'd only have
that many nothing I'll green goo plea
my vision is turning green I died holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] Facebook what I uh
uneven I don't even know ah you son of a
[ __ ] got the doorknob gonna kill you
[ __ ] oh man
okay
oh no that killed you maybe it's like a
distance I am why did I jump in the
radiated water Oh No
it has no doorknob Oh ain't that a shame
that works ha ha ha knife knife dahlias
cruise cruise goose goose goose goose
goose goose goose goose goods goods
goods guys go together follow the light
keep walking I don't know be ready
no-no-no
why is everything green man good you're
dead huh [ __ ] you
I don't think it's a good idea to follow
this person what person who person who's
a person I didn't see a person what's
with these friggin how they go home
I seriously shouldn't follow him who
what uh now everything's not green a
sick [ __ ] and follow him Who am I
following I didn't say anyone now
everything's not green follow this
person okay alright so don't fall him
that's good
fine by me I'm not gonna follow him oh
man now everything's harder to see now
that it's not group wait what dot huh
well there we go
oh good ok I'm climbing wait well that's
not Simon's clothes Who am I
was it restart the game somehow what why
ha ha oh I'm the police officer oh whoa
hello
yeah here get out here screw all of you
all of you ow who's [ __ ] me wait
what the hey wait hang on what's
happening what happened don't restart
why are you restarting the whole time Oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] man up ensue this has been
like this whole game has been the
craziest range of emotions I've ever
been through in my entire life I've been
spaced I've been angry I've been scared
oh man this is this game is doing things
to me I don't like them I don't like
them oh man I have a feeling that's
gonna record for so long that my fraps
is gonna break or something I don't know
I can't even go through there I don't
even know what's going on okay somehow I
got here and there's like a whole bunch
of you [ __ ]
and that's better okay oh [ __ ] Mike
who's shooting come on come on man
what Oh what
who's sure Wow where do you come from
I'm so confused
someone shooting me from over there
I don't know who I can't get in there oh
[ __ ] hell I can't I can't get in
there
okay uh I'm [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] confused
I'm I'm like royally confused I'm I
don't even know anymore I'm so
unbelievably confused I'm like
what am i doing oh I see oh okay all
right
whoa hello two hours later a pickaxe oh
let's just go oh [ __ ] Oh balls can't see
a thing okay apparently I'm climbing a
ladder that I didn't even know is there
whatever just get me to the end I just
want to get to the end I want to go home
I want to go see my dog I want to go eat
it tasty meal I want to be anywhere but
in this game I have got to be close to
the end don't I
I've got to be close to the end I would
have cut it shorter if I knew this was
longer [ __ ] you know what bring it on
all you [ __ ] I can't see it I can't
see [ __ ]
I can't see anything what am I looking
at here
over here no yes I can't see [ __ ]
there's no way to pass it I can't what
the [ __ ] I can't see anything
Oh God God and hell okay I'm done I'm
done I cannot keep playing this anymore
I literally can't it's too much on me
I'm so stressed right now I'm so
unbelievably stressed I don't even care
how close I am to the end I can't see
I'm not I'm done I'm gone okay I'm gone
[ __ ] alright so I'll pick this up later
down the road way down the road I don't
even care if I'm two inches from the end
I wouldn't care cuz I'm done you know
what I'm done
so Jed I've got I'm not done I'm just
kidding I'm not gonna stop why would I
stop why aren't I stop I'm fooling
myself I don't see anything but you know
what let's turn up the gamma knob can't
do that
I'll can't do that in here that's just
silly can't can't turn up the camera
can use anything no way to pass whatever
hell's in front of me no way in hell to
do anything ha why do I go oh you're
[ __ ] [ __ ] I couldn't say that I
better be close to the end I better and
you all better be grateful for me
playing this son of a [ __ ] cuz I'm
pissed I am pissed I'm pissed I'm gonna
keep being pitch oh you are son I don't
even [ __ ] care hope you die hope you
die twice got a lantern oh yeah oh man
you guys do not know how stressed I am
right now I'm unbelievably stress
hi thank you hello you gotta stand right
there oh no you're gonna come after me
that's cool too
either way oh man
the human mind can only take so much
abuse before it shatters like a grape
should will oh yeah it should shouldn't
it shouldn't it it should shouldn't it
it should shouldn't it ah [ __ ] pump up
hell is pump up
okay you know what good you stay right
there I'm so glad that you're taking the
time to think about your transgressions
how I was too anxious from the end cuz
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
that was really good I was really good
custom cabinet it was no it was I was
really really really aggravated because
I was very stressed
I was scared way too much for way too
long and I was pushing myself to keep
going and it gets to me and it makes me
go insane like seriously playing
minigames is very stressful on me like
seriously my heart hurt after a great
too many scares ah oh man but it's okay
because all in all that was a fantastic
collaborative effort oh I was so
confused out at all at I'll be like it
was just I couldn't handle it anymore
I'm broke I snapped like a twig under
the pressure I just got crunched I was
lost snap and I couldn't take it anymore
oh man that's how I go look at pictures
of puppies I'm gonna
humma do summer I did not take six
minutes
I'm not matter how I might ago gonna go
run Oh God
I'm gonna do something else
holy hell man so thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more videos and I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video bye
Oh